heavy rain coming down there
in mountains edge we have reports of
hail there too we had earlier we'll show
that to you
coming up but first look at this new
cell that has developed behind me here
this
is north right along the 2 15 beltway
you can see the rain shaft coming down
producing not only rain but lightning
too there's a look at that cell a pretty
big cell right now there's the northern
beltway
elsewhere remaining dry showers right
around mccarran
showers also around southern highlands
where you did have a storm there too
one flash flood warning still remains in
effect this is until 5 30 p.m
this is over state route 160 mount
potency here this is points westward
prop over towards the west there too
that's our only flash flood warning
right now
storms all around us so we're not done
just yet scattered storms drifting from
the north to the south you can see it
lincoln county all the way to nine
county drifting towards our region so
we do have chances of more storms to
develop for tonight
scattered storms are in the forecast all
through tomorrow too some could be
severe
thunderstorms will produce gusty winds
lightning and downpours that's what
we're seeing outside right now with that
latest cell
and drier and hotter for the holidays i
got all this and more
coming up for you in your most accurate
forecast